we're going to try to go for two they
want to extend the game sure but if the
three is there on the driving kick
believe me they're gonna take it it's
Caruso on bogdanovich to start Joseph
Diallo Wiseman as well Ivy to inbound
time out
wait Detroit Detroit have a timeout they
didn't have a time-out
they did not have a timeout that was
their last one and Ivy the rookie made
the crucial mistake of calling a timeout
and you can see I looked immediately
over at Dwayne Casey and his arms were
in the air knowing that his team did not
have a timeout left wow it's a technical
foul that's a mistake by a young player
wow
[Applause]
that is
oh my God goodness get to shoot a
technical and get the ball
oh
that that is oh that is huge you can see
there's panic because he couldn't see
anybody in and you look at the aloe
saying no no no no no no no and look at
Bardon what are you doing son a lot
look at there's t look at look at
Patrick Mary's he's not calling for a
timeout he's calling for a technical
obsessive timeout it's a technical foul